all right let's do our rankings we do
that every Wednesday morning and there's
been a shake-up chrises at the top of
the Power Rankings thanks to the
Baltimore Ravens taking down the New
England Patriots there's a new
number-one team for the first time this
year and it is the last unbeaten team in
the NFL the San Francisco 49ers bump up
from number two to number one the Saints
claim the two spot the Ravens have to be
ahead of the Patriots I know the Ravens
have two losses but they just thumped
the Patriots Patriots down to four
Seahawks up to five the bills bump up
two spots to number six
Packers drop three to number seven after
losing the Chargers Chiefs up three to
eight Texans up three to nine the rams
hold steady at 10 give me your best and
or your worst for the top ten for this
week's power ring well no I you know
what for the most part I really like it
I do and you know your point about the
Ravens again this is about where these
teams are right now not what they did
you know four weeks ago or five weeks
ago I think the Ravens haven't injected
themselves as certainly one of the three
best teams in football when you go up to
Seattle and win a game like that and
then the nfe to Patriots come to your
hometown and you beat them like you said
pretty handily there yeah you deserve to
be there so credit to you I would well I
don't even gonna get into that the 49ers
I do think are the best team in the
sport I do what are you gonna get into
what are you gonna say like what if the
Patriots just squeaked out a win in
Baltimore last week would you have kept
them in number one yes you would yes
yeah okay because the 49ers you could
argue just squeaked out a win against
the bad Cardinals team on Thursday night
yeah I mean yes they were up 28 to 14
and looked like they were on their way
to blowing them out and then yes some
things happen but I get you okay that's
good also now you get into this range I
just want to hear you know you get in
through like 5 6 7 8 9 min 10 I really
give you a lot of credit first off for
putting the Rams in the top 10 I think
they are and then one of the 10 best
teams in football right now I think a
lot of people are forgetting about them
and I know the envies NFC is packed with
talented teams but I still look at the
Rams and go watch out there's a lot of
things there that
like about their team where they make
this second half run so I guess that's
what I want to say to you more than
anything good job I'm putting the Rams
in the top ten well and I put them in
the top ten last week as well they held
steady solid yeah yeah but but but you
know no up no down they didn't play they
didn't win they didn't lose and I wanted
it I try to keep the teams that don't
play in the same spot that they're in if
possible sometimes they'll go up a spot
or two if the teams in front of them is
stumble but the Rams I think deserved to
be at number ten and they should stay at
number ten they were leaped by the
Chiefs and the Texans but you know the
both of those teams had impressive
victories and the the Chiefs win
resulted in the Vikings dropping five
spots let's take a look at the the
second ten the Cowboys bumped up two
spots to number 11
after winning on Monday night the
Vikings are down to number 12 five spots
lower than they were last week after
losing to the Chiefs Eagles up 1 to 13
the Panthers are up 1 to 14 Steelers
bump up to to number 15 after beating
the Colts who fell seven spots from nine
all the way to number 16 Raiders at four
and four are 17 they're up three
Chargers also up three at four and five
after beating the Packers Jaguars down
three to number 19 and the Lions round
out the top twenty three four and one
lines dropped two spots after losing to
the Raiders and yeah it gets tougher and
when you get to the back half but I feel
pretty good about my second ten what do
you think well my only one I don't like
Love on there I think you're a little
too harsh on the Colts like oh I think
16 is too low and I know the Steelers
beat them and you feel this great need
that you always have to put them in
front of them but there was like it I
watched that film yesterday if the Colts
and Steelers play 20 times the Colts win
19 you know the game felt just right for
the Steelers the quarterback got hurt
Brian Hoyer threw a pick six you know
who was a Chester Rodgers after they got
a safety dropped the ensuing punt return
that you get after the safety and gave
the the Steelers the short field so I
think that's where my probably my
biggest problem with your whole rankings
is I think I still would I would have I
can understand you having Cowboys 11
Vikings 12
I think I would have put the Colts 13
and then bumped everybody down there I
also think you should you're not nice
enough to your own team I think I'd
still put the the Vikings in front of
the Cowboys maybe yeah I probably would
I would've like whoa whoa are you saying
the Vikings are gonna beat the Cowboys
on Sunday night is that why you would do
it I'm not saying that but I'm saying
right now I think they've proven to me
that they've played better football
through ten weeks than the Dallas
Cowboys have whoo I think we would both
agree were a little shaky once again on
Monday Night Football and yeah it looks
like on the scoreboard they won that
game convincingly but I think you and I
both know that wasn't that convincing
yeah I don't disagree with that I just
believe that the Cowboys will beat the
Vikings and I was trying to prepare
myself for the onslaught from you which
would be if the Vikings were ahead of
the Cowboys you saying to me
also you think the Vikings are gonna win
on Sunday night when they play at Dallas
so I was influenced by that and I try to
finagle the Power Rankings so for some
of the games that are upcoming if the
two teams are close I like to get them
stacked one after the other and let's
see what happens when they get together
on the field Raiders Chargers 17 and 18
they're playing on Thursday night we'll
see which of the two teams deserves the
higher ranking let's do a quick
run-through
the last 12 on the list the Titans who I
just got up and down they go all year
long they're now four and five they fall
spoot two spots to 21
the Broncos up three to 22 the Bears I
just kinda you know there's really not
much movement it's the but the bad teams
are the bad teams that you know they've
declared themselves the Broncos after
they get up three spots the Bears stay
at 23 the Cardinal stay at 24 the Bucs
move up one spot even though they lost I
give them some credit for playing the
Seahawks tough the Browns I dropped four
spots to 26 Giants don't move at 27 the
Dolphins get a little bumped for getting
their first win of the season they're up
ahead now of the Falcons Jets Washington
and Bengals yeah anything stand out to
you in that I don't think there's
anything that I look at like too crazily
crazy there I don't I mean I think
you're okay
the Bears I think I would have them
about right there that's where I did
first go just to look at that I think
got the bottom forward team's correct I
think those I don't know I might have
had I might have had the Jets below the
Washington Redskins but other than that
I think I think I can deal with your
bottom bottom 10 there now I want to go
back to the top 10 just for a second if
I can I am surprised that you have the
bills ahead of the Packers I know the
Packers came off ugly loss but the bills
haven't exactly like instilled
confidence in us lately I mean I know
they beat the Redskins the other day but
that wasn't pretty the week before they
lost to the Eagles the week before that
it was a game against the Dolphins where
it was in the balance for a while so I
just am surprised where the Packers have
grit played really good football leading
up to this week I guess I'm a little
surprised that you let the Bills jump
the Packers well and it all came down to
one primary thing the Packers stunk on
Sunday and they needed to drop farther
than they did and if I would have put
the Packers at 6 the penalty for losing
at LA to a Chargers team that they
should have destroyed that that and look
I'll admit the Packers were one of my
best bets of the week we picked three
games against the spread that we feel
great about every week in the joint
Chris Sims unbuttoned pft p.m. podcast
we'll do it again tomorrow the Packers
were one of the teams I said would
easily cover the spread I get a little
upset when I get let down by one of my
best bets teams so I wasn't gonna drop
him only two spots I'm dropping him
three and I should have dropped them
farther for letting me down and making
me look even dumber than I already love
it that's where that's not the answer I
wanted to hear the the vindictive Mike
Florio gosh you're like you're like
you're like part of the the Mafia
sometimes you just gotta like you
crossed me I gotta get you back I've ER
and I yeah what are you implying
I'm implying that you're crazy that's
what I'm okay all right watch the Mafia
references there Sims I'm Italian if you
haven't known
yes I know thank you I know anyway I'm
just giving you hard time I really did
think the Packers deserved to drop more
than two spots because they were they
were horrible on both sides of the ball
they didn't show up uh yeah whatever
Aaron Rodgers was saying after the game
whatever message he was sending it was
clear and it was loud and I think it was
directed and you know the speculation we
had and we don't know what happened and
maybe the story will come out at some
point they got to LA on Friday night
maybe they went out and partied a little
too hard alee and it carried over into
Sunday yeah I think so did you just say
heartily heartily they partied a little
too hard alee there that are real
heartily okay okay well sure I haven't
had that in my thought I'll tell you one
thing
I don't play Russian roulette with words
I will only use words that I know are
words I don't just say it and hope that
MDS is gonna save me on Twitter 20
minutes later yeah well I do I love I
look dangerous
okay but I think you are right I think
that's what Aaron Rodgers was calling
out and you know we've had this
conversation a lot this is what happens
in Miami but especially can happen on
the California trips especially teams
from the Midwest of the East Coast
because they will go out there on a
Friday and hey Friday is that day where
a lot of NFL guys get out a little bit
and you need to go have a beer at the
bar or go to the club for a little while
you don't stay out late but that is a
night in the NFL where hey these are
grown men they got to blow off a little
steam some of them here and there but
yeah if I had to connect the dots or
read between the lines there I think
that's exactly what Aaron Rodgers was
probably referring to that you know guys
got out to LA at all
look it's LA we got stuff to do and you
know the weather's great let's get
outside let's go here let's go there and
maybe broke them out of the routine that
that has made them successful so far
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports